[Musique]
haslem annette le col avant de commencer
je voulais être très franc avec vous
je n'ai jamais réussi à parler en public
je pense que c'est pas c'est pas ma
place je n'aime pas être devant les
projecteurs
d'ailleurs lui au moins âgés atteints
n'arrive pas à croire paul tu as marre
actes a dit mme arafat a depuis passé
sur la télé tu as parlé en direct à 12
millions de personnes doivent
normalement mille personnes devant toi
c'est gérable et ça se voit c'est pas
tout vous êtes très impressionnant
d'ailleurs avant de continuer pour me
sentir un peu dans mon élément
j'aimerais vous prendre en photo donc je
vous demanderais juste de deux sourires
de me faire un petit sourire et ça sera
une photo de groupe
merci donc maintenant que vous avez
compris que je suis pas à l'aise sur
scène il ya une autre chose que j'aime
pas on fait un pas aussi nombreuses les
nuls
l'artiste je lui préfère plutôt assez
nombreuses lignes le photographe
pour moi ça a été toujours la finalité
de mon travail c'est de vraiment de
prendre les gens en photo les moments
que je partage avec eux avant la prise
de photos les histoires qu'ils me
racontent et c et j'arrive même là des
fois à ne pas aller jusqu'à prendre la
photo je m'arrête juste dans l'histoire
et je fais un peu moins égoïste je garde
ça pour moi donc pardon c'est l'émotion
en fait ouais si l'artiste exposant
galerie fait des faits des festivals et
caetera et malgré que j'aime ça beaucoup
et c'est pas vrai parce que je suis
obligé de dire hier il ya ma galerie ce
qui le regarde mais en fait quand je dis
c'est la finalité vraiment c'est la
prise de vue il ya une chose que j'aime
pas aussi on fait déjà pas mon statut
d'entrepreneur culturel en fait je
trouve que malgré que la maison est un
projet qui me tient tellement à coeur et
c'est un projet qu'on a monté il a trois
ans mais voici le photographe et un peu
handicapé par sa parce que ça lui
consomme beaucoup de temps qu'il qu'il
aurait pu investir dans son travail
photographique
voilà j'aime pas aussi le statut
d'entrepreneur parce que en tant que
photographe c'est si triste été très
difficile pour moi de d'aller vers la
cnss d'aller vers leur base à d'aller
faire le ministère de la culture que je
salue d'ici et qui malheureusement et
heureusement qu'il a compris aujourd'hui
qu'il fallait vraiment instaurer un
cadre juridique et légal pour des
centres culturels privés pour que les
gens quand vous quand ils ont envie
d'ouvrir un centre culturel ne perdent
pas une année de leur temps à le faire
par contre je suis là pour vous une
chose que en fait que j'aime beaucoup
c'est c'est la seule chose qui me qui
aujourd'hui mon mutisme me le patient et
qui me donne l'énergie chaque jour
vraiment de bosser et de donner cette
chose là c'est c'est ces jeunes là c'est
le procès des photos des jeunes de la
première promotion du projet vision
solidaire qu'on est en train de mettre
en place avec l'aide de la fondation de
ressources au sein de la maison de
l'image ces gens là sont issus des
quartiers populaires de tadamoun el
kabaria le mda pour ne citer que ça donc
pour ceux qui n'ont pas entendu parler
de ce projet avec vision solidaire c'est
c'est une initiative qui qui qui se veut
d'une part innovantes et d'une part
aussi à l'ordre de ce qui se fait dans
les pays étrangers sur le projet
consiste à former chaque année 30 jeunes
issus des quartiers des quartiers
populaires sur limité d'une image la
photographie la vidéographie
l'illustration le dessin et le webdesign
donc c'est une formation de six mois qui
est suivie avant de passer une formation
de six mois qui est donnée par des
formateurs de très grande qualité des
formateurs qui bossent aussi qui ont
fait leurs preuves dans le dans le
métier donc ces six mois de formation
après six mois de formation on les
insère dans des entreprises partenaires
pour qu'ils fassent d'un stage de trois
mois et dans ce stage là il se comprend
un peu à la réalité de de la vie
professionnelle
après on les récupère pendant un mois
pour une formation complémentaire
et puis en les divisant groupe où ils
sont amenés à travailler sur des projets
de fin d'études
et l'idée de ces projets c'est vraiment
de mettre en avant leurs quartiers là où
ils habitent
les gens qui les entourent et essayé à
travers ce qu'ils font de vraiment
changer l'image qu'on a de ces quartiers
là quand on a lancé l'appel à
candidatures de la première
ah non pardon on s'attendait pas à
recevoir ont presque trois semaines plus
de 580 dossier ce qui vraiment montre
qu' il ya un réel besoin dans ces
quartiers là et que ces gens là à cause
de la situation qui soit financière ou
la situation sociale où ils vivent
ils ont un très grand potentiel ils ont
très centré créatif et je vous assure
que ça a été vraiment très très dur de
choisir que 30
si on avait les moyens les capacités et
l'énergie dont de les prendre tous on
l'aurait fait donc je vous disais que
ces jeunes là quand on les a quand on
leur a demandé de présenter leur appel à
candidatures leur demander de faire une
petite vidéo d'une minute où il
présentait leurs rêves leurs ambitions
un projet qu'il souhaiterait faire après
la fin de la formation et et on
s'attendait pas quand je vous ai dit
vraiment à voir que cuda une très grande
c'est que ces régions-là fait mon sens
est une très grande pépinière pour
l'industrie culturelle et j'insiste pour
appeler ça l'industrie
parce que la culture a sa place en
tunisie c'est ça peut être un moteur
pour vraiment ont mené le pays très loin
et créer des emplois
on stigmatise souvent les photographes
en leur faisant des petites blagues par
rapport au photographe de quartier
photographe de mariage mais c'est limité
qui se respecte c'est qu'il sait des
gens qui mémorise nos nos mémoires et
nos événements et c'est un métier très
intéressant donc je vous disais que ces
gens là ils arrêtaient vraiment très
créatif et dès maintenant nous au sein
de la maison d'image on en a repéré deux
qu'on va engager qu'on va recruter
officiellement appris la fin de la
formation
tellement ils ont du potentiel et on
compte beaucoup aussi sur les autres
entreprises partenaires ou ceux qui sont
présents ici pour faire de même et venir
voir que ces gens là à les rencontrer et
pourquoi pas puiser dans ce vivier
très intéressant j'ai commencé menthol
de parler de je n'aime pas je n'aime pas
je n'a pas jusqu'à arriver à la chose
que j'aime en fait ce que je veux que
vous reteniez de ce talk c'est que
essayer de sortir de vos zones de
confort n'est pas peur de faire des
choses que vous n'aimez pas aujourd'hui
ça peut vous sembler quelque chose de
contraignant mais dans le futur
je suis sûr que ce que vous avez fait
aujourd'hui vous allez le trouver après
dans une situation une autre c'est
qu'est ce que j'allais dire si pardon
en fait s'ils avaient pas voici le voici
de l'artiste je n'aurais pas eu cette un
peu cette notoriété nécessaire mais
heureusement qu'elle n'est pas
obligatoire pour pouvoir ouvrir un
centre culturel en tunisie il n'y avait
pas cette maison d'image qui était censé
être un lieu de rencontres d'échangés
etc sachant que dès le début on avait
mis une liste de missions et objectifs
et parmi ses missions là il y avait à la
9e place l'intervention dans les
quartiers populaires et est difficile
nous n'aurons jamais su que ces
quartiers-là avait été dans le dans le
besoin et on s'est rendu compte après le
temps que ce qu'on avait mis dans la
neuvième place c'était vraiment la
priorité aujourd'hui c'est l'éducation
c'est l'éducation à la culture visuelle
à l'histoire de l'art parce que je suis
certain je suis confiant que ça peut
changer toute la l'image de la tunisie
et il n'y avait pas quand je vous ai dit
ce projet aussi vision solidaire je
n'aurais jamais trouvé un quelque chose
qui me qui m'obligerait chaque jour à me
rêvais à faire des nuits blanches
que ce soit moi ou toute l'équipe du
projet qui travaille sur ça et ces
jeunes là je le répète encore mérite
toute notre attention et toute notre
bonne volonté
parce que c'est pas seulement parce
qu'ils sont issus des quartiers
difficiles au populaire mais ce qu'ils
ont beaucoup de choses à donner
ils sont capables de montrer vraiment
de très belles choses et je suis certain
que d'ici la fin de cette première année
nous aurons développé une nouvelle
génération qui contournera les problèmes
liés à la culture et à l'image juste
chose avant de terminer je vous invite
tous vraiment à si vous invitons à
passer à la maison de l'image à
rencontrer ces gens-là à leur parler et
à voir ce qu'ils en occident à faire et
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]